oh my god so what inspired you with this
number tonight um well pink's my
favorite color and i always tend to like
to be comfortable so i felt like this
was like rock and roll and the vmas is a
fun award show you can kind of go cash
yeah i usually go cash but honey this is
a little bit yeah got some crystals on
yeah the crystals dress it up a little
bit
i love it does it feel good to be back
yeah so i'm here tonight i'm presenting
an award and um and i'm dropping uh new
music in a month that's what i hear so
give us a scoop about this new music of
course you recently collaborated with
mod who's hanging out in the background
looking like uh
you know your leading man right there
but so what other kind of collaborations
and music can we expect from you so i
have a lot of collaborations on this new
record of mine um
maybe a collab with mgk
and some other cool artists like that
travis parker
um and yeah the album's like super rock
and roll kind of like pop punk and it's
a good time and yeah really seeing new
music in like a month or two that is
wonderful does it feel good to be
releasing new music from yeah absolutely
and your fans have been wanting it like
crazy and i'm going on tour next year
too that is awesome so many good things
coming your way right now what are you
looking forward to most about this
evening
um well i'm just super stoked to be in
town in new york city
my boyfriend with your man over there hi
mom we're excited to be at the vmas and
i'm just celebrating music so good so
have you heard the big news tonight that
britney spears is newly engaged
[Music]